things are very rapidly escalating in
Russia we've been waiting and wondering
well what is Putin's eventual move here
what was expected by some to be an
extremely rapid total defeat of Ukraine
of course did not happen
uh and over the last couple of weeks we
have seen Russian forces actually
repelled and retreating and the question
amid continued concerns about Vladimir
Putin's Health has been what is the end
game how is he going to ultimately get
out of this or is he ultimately going to
get out of this the U.S embassy is now
warning Americans to get out of of
Russia this is uh the clearest
declaration and the most comprehensive
of you just have to get out now many of
you might be saying why are there
Americans still in Russia uh there are
so many different reasons why there are
Americans still in Russia and we're
going to talk about that in a moment a
CNN reporting the U.S embassy in Moscow
issued a security alert overnight that
again urged U.S citizens to leave Russia
immediately while there are still
options for departing the country the
alert comes in the wake of Russian
President Putin's order for partial
mobilization of Russian men to fight in
his war in Ukraine
quote Russia May refuse to acknowledge
dual Nationals U.S citizenship deny
their access to U.S Consular assistance
prevent their departure from Russia and
conscript dual Nationals for military
service that is a really scary statement
which we will talk about
the embassy has consistently warned
Americans not to travel to Russia and to
depart the country immediately if there
the embassy alert urged U.S citizens to
quote avoid all political or social
protests do not photograph security
Personnel at these events noting that
the right to Peaceful assembly and
freedom of expression are not guaranteed
in Russia
very different situation that Americans
in Russia have to understand
leaving is a very good idea at this
point but at the same time there are
people who simply didn't research the
situation properly who are there now one
of the things that's important to
understand about the dual citizenship
thing if you are in a country in which
you hold citizenship and you hold an
additional citizenship meaning you are
an American citizen and you are a
Russian Citizen and you are in Russia
it is often the case that in that
country you are only viewed through the
lens of that citizenship if you were
a French American dual Citizen and you
were in Russia this is not an issue if
you are an American Russian dual Citizen
and you were in Russia the American
citizenship isn't particularly relevant
at least not as far as Russia cares if
you are a russian-american dual Citizen
and you're in Russia and Russia says hey
you know what we're we're conscripting
individuals to fight in the military and
you go oh no uh I need help from the
American Embassy because I'm also an
American citizen it is very common that
that will be denied to you now the uh
American authorities might say well we
can still try to help but you will often
be denied Consular Services because at
the end of the day you are a Russian
Citizen and this is something that
um uh yeah I've I've talked about and
thought about in other terms with regard
to my Argentinian dual citizenship where
um there have been discussions of what
if x y or Z happen while in Argentina
this is obviously much more serious and
and much more significant now some
reactions I've read are more or less
like shouldn't these Americans have
already left
um I I'm actually I'm sympathetic to the
people that are there and that are also
American citizens it is really difficult
to uproot your life there are lots of
people
whose entire lives despite being
American Russian dual citizens their
entire lives are in Russia they were
born in the U.S to Russian parents and
went to Russia at age three okay that's
that's an American citizen nominally
whose entire life is arguably in Russia
and so the idea of well just get out
what are you doing there uh it's a more
complicated statement than than might
appear the other thing about this is
that not everybody has the money or
financial resources to get out and to
come back to the United States it may
not be obvious how they would make a
living in the United States if you are
working in Russia and this is often
something that comes up when we talk
about undocumented immigration to the
United States and many on the right love
to pretend that people that come to the
United States illegally kind of doing it
on a whim kind of doing it for fun for
entertainment almost like some kind of
Tourism of some sense and what's often
missing from that conversation is that
these are people's lives and uprooting
or moving your life to a different
country is a really really big deal and
so even when you are coming to the
United States undocumented from uh
Central South America looking for work
as as is this typical situation that we
talk about that's a massive decision
that no one makes lightly and it's often
missing total lack of empathy when we
talk about and think about what it is
that these folks are doing here not
related to hey Americans it's time to
get out of Russia but that also is going
on but these folks are not on vacation
is the important thing to understand
um and this now gets us back to
what is Putin willing to do how far is
Putin willing to go what is he
potentially considering and is Putin
sick is Putin erratic is Putin not
thinking clearly and the answers to all
of these questions uh May well be yes so
no there are some very non-trivial
decisions to be made by Americans in
Russia
and the next four to six weeks of what
Putin does or doesn't do could be
extremely important in terms of the
entire course that this war is going to
take scary moment and yes uh all other
caveats aside people have lives people
are all these things that we've talked
about for people living in Russia the
recommendation is to get out my
preference would be not to end up
potentially conscripted into the Russian
army now of course I am not a Russian
dual Citizen and I have no connections
to Russia so it's easy for me to say we
are seeing more of these abortion
denials for pregnant minors in the state
of Ohio this is the expected outcome of
what Republicans are doing no matter
what they say about this is regrettable
or this was not our intent this was the
predictable and expected outcome of the
states that are going hard against
abortion now that Roe v Wade has been
overturned by the Supreme Court we had a
story like this about six weeks ago and
now we have at least two more
cincinnati.com from the Ohio Capital
Journal reporting
two more pregnant miners who were raped
were denied Ohio abortions
these are disgusting and sickening
circumstances the article reads at least
two more minors made pregnant by sexual
assault
were forced to leave Ohio to avoid
having their rapists babies according to
sworn affidavits filed by abortion
providers
the affidavits were filed in Cincinnati
as part of a lawsuit aimed at stopping
the enforcement of Ohio's strict new
abortion law originally paused for two
weeks the enforcement delay will be
extended until at least October 12th
if true and remember I don't sometimes
say affidavits aren't evidence
affidavits aren't evidence but they
should be looked at
um and evaluated if true the affidavits
show that a 10 year old from Columbus
Ohio was not the only child or teen rape
victim forced to leave the state they
also describe more than two dozen other
instances in which the abortion law put
women under extreme duress the
description includes those of three
women who threaten suicide and they
include two women with cancer who could
not terminate their pregnancies and also
couldn't get cancer treatment while they
were pregnant
that is a disgusting double-edged sword
and remember we talked about how this
develops
two things they can't get the abortion
because of Ohio abortion law and they
can't get the cancer treatment because
the cancer doctors are scared that the
cancer treatment could cause a
miscarriage and that they could be they
being the doctors could be charged for
facilitating an abortion
think of that it doesn't sound like what
the United States in 2022 is supposed to
be but unfortunately we are now getting
more and more of these stories another
three examples were of women whose
fetuses had severe abnormalities or
other conditions that made a successful
pregnancy impossible
even so they couldn't get abortions in
Ohio you know one of the things that's
often said
in opposition to abortion being legal in
most cases is these mothers shouldn't be
allowed to play God with people's lives
who are other people to make decisions
about other people's lives and you know
the truth is that decisions about other
people's lives are made all the time and
are often made at the end of life and at
the end of life when it is identified
that there is no brain activity and no
possibility for the recovery of brain
activity quote other people make
decisions about those lives and yet when
you have fetuses where there is no brain
activity they will not develop normally
these Republicans say no the mothers
shouldn't be allowed to make decisions
in those cases it's absolutely
horrifying so you've got situations
where you've got the potential for dead
moms and then orphans if even the mom
survives long enough to give birth if
even the fetus survives and um you've
got moms being forced to quote give
birth although to call it that is a bit
of an exaggeration or a misnomer
to dead fetuses and this is truly just
the tip of the iceberg many of these
stories will never even become known and
we have to ask who benefits who is it
good for
for women to be forced to stop Cancer
Treatments to travel out of state to get
an abortion and then to come back and
continue cancer treatment who benefits
from that who benefits from that and
remember they would talk about the
Obamacare death panels these are the
real death penalties you know you had
Sarah Palin going around death panel
this death panel that didn't exist and
by the way by the way it is actually the
denial of Health Care Services
altogether
that could be argued to be the real
death penalties this is by Design now I
know Republicans will say that it is not
by the design we're not trying to create
these situations but it is predictable
it is predictable that this would happen
when you overturn Roe v Wade and then
States pass these horrifyingly strict
abortion laws what's the end game here
that's my question to you what is truly
the end game for Republicans is it just
to continue having situations like this
or is it that they believe these types
of situations will get people to rethink
their behavior in some way I don't I
don't actually know what the end game is
but what we do know is that banning
abortion doesn't eliminate abortion that
has been widely studied and we know that
so find me on Twitter at dpacman and
answer me the question what is the end
game here
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is primarily
funded by our Audience by you by people
who watch a YouTube clip or listen to
the podcast or watch us maybe on Free
Speech TV or listen on the radio this
happens through the membership program
you can sign up easily quickly I promise
you painlessly at joinpakman.com and
you'll get the daily bonus show as well
as commercial free audio and video
streams of the show and so many other
great things hurricane Ian is bearing
down on the State of Florida after
ravaging Cuba we've talked about it to
some degree as of this moment two and a
half million Floridians are without
power and we are told that fatalities
are in the hundreds the federal
government should do what it can to help
Florida that is my position it has been
the case with hurricanes in other states
and tornadoes and whatever else I am
consistent on that issue but many
Republicans are not we've seen so many
Republicans vote against Federal funding
for disasters in other states but then
go and beg the federal government for
help when the disaster is in their state
that gets us to Florida Republican
Governor Ron DeSantis Ron DeSantis who
has been one of the wildest critics of
President Joe Biden is now all of a
sudden being very nice because he needs
Joe Biden's help he needs the federal
government's help what happened to
Florida
being a big boy patriotic
self-sufficient State who doesn't need
anybody's help and they have all the
freedom in the world well all of a
sudden they're issuing mandatory
evacuation orders which I agree with but
they're not exactly the freedom that Ron
DeSantis has touted all of a sudden
DeSantis wants Federal cash for disaster
relief even though DeSantis in 2013
voted no for superstorm Sandy Relief
funding for New York and New Jersey is
he a hypocrite of course he is but it's
been really funny watching him try to
equip equivocate when being interviewed
by Sean Hannity on Fox News which we're
going to get to in a moment Newsweek
article DeSantis Praises Biden as
Florida Governor changes tone before
hurricane Ian what a surprise what a
surprise Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
has expressed gratitude towards
President Joe Biden for his cooperation
as hurricane Ian is due to hit the state
let's take a look at the video clip
which you will find uh is the Santa
singing a very different tone about Joe
Biden let's talk about you had a
conversation with the president today
earlier in the day there had been talk
that the president spoke with Mayors but
not you uh but apparently the president
reached out to you tonight can you tell
us about that conversation and in the
aftermath of the storm what what support
Floridians can expect from the federal
government
well Sean you know what I said today is
uh you know my phone lines open When
people's lives and their property are at
risk like this you know we all need to
work together right when people's lives
are at risk we need to work together
otherwise I'm going to tell horrible
corrosive lies regardless of party lines
uh the bind Administration has approved
our request for a pre-landfall
declaration and did that very quickly so
so we're thankful for that you know
obviously as this the impacts are known
uh you know there's going to be more
requests particularly for individual
assistance for Floridians that may have
been displaced you know and it's my
sense that the administration you know
wants to help I think they realize that
this is a really significant storm and
there's a lot of people that you know
we're working with the locals we work
very well with them of course at the
state level but we really need everyone
working together to make sure people
have their needs tended to this is about
a bunch of different things so let's see
if we can go through it first of all is
DeSantis a hypocrite on this issue of
federal funding of course he is and so
many Republicans are you had
um members elected officials from the
Midwest who were begging for money for
tornado uh uh recovery who had voted
against money for New York and New
Jersey for superstorm Sandy recovery
back in 2013 and I could go on the list
is so long and the earthquakes the Rand
Paul Kentucky all these different
they're they're all Hypocrites okay so
that's one layer and DeSantis is of
course a hypocrite second thing
when DeSantis talks about this is not
the time for pettiness this is not the
time for political division Etc he's
agreeing that much of what he does is
simply Petty
and when it's inconvenient or whether he
believes that people's lives are
actually on the line he didn't seem to
believe it with covet but now with the
hurricane he seems to all of a sudden he
goes no this isn't the time for any of
that now we're just going to behave like
normal people and we're actually going
to work together because we actually
need need something here so that's the
second thing is he's essentially
admitting a lot of his uh his nonsense
is completely Petty and merely political
but then there's a third aspect which is
that Ron DeSantis is on the
gubernatorial ballot in what is it five
weeks five and a half weeks or something
like that he will either be re-elected
the governor of Florida potentially
booing him into running for president in
2024 or he will lose to Charlie Chris
now the polling looks fine for DeSantis
right now for the most part save one
recent poll but DeSantis is also acting
this way out of self-preservation
because he realizes much like Trump's
covid response destroyed Trump's
reelection and much like bad disaster
responses in other states have
dramatically impacted the approval
ratings of those leaders think Greg
Abbott in Texas although Abbott has now
recovered it's been long enough he'll
probably still win re-election to
Governor against Beto in Texas DeSantis
realizes that the timing of this
hurricane if there were to be a bad
response would be really bad for his
re-election so that's what's happening
oh and then there's a fourth aspect to
this as well
the Trump narcissistic Style
is extraordinarily transactional and so
to some degree this is also DeSantis
thinking to himself
if I'm nicer to Biden on TV the federal
government might give us more money and
of course Biden knows that this is what
DeSantis is doing but to praise Biden
quite frankly Biden doesn't care Biden
realizes that it's his job to say yes
when Americans need something Americans
in Florida need something right now so
Biden's going to get them the money
Biden's not perfect there's no doubt
about it but on this there is a really
sharp contrast between Biden and Trump
trump even in situations of disaster
relief is extraordinarily Petty and
narcissistic and political Biden's just
going to send the money Biden doesn't
really care whether Ron DeSantis is
being nice to him on TV or not so
there's the santis all of a sudden
saying no I mean things are going fine
with Biden and we know all the reasons
why four different layers as to why this
is what's going on
speaking of Ron DeSantis this is a sort
of like if the shoe fits type moment a
Ron DeSantis appointee
War
a Ku Klux Klan they're calling it a
costume but I think it's really a
uniform you can't really get that as a
costume and has now resigned this is an
interesting story that is not like a
major shock to many of us Huffington
Post reports Ron DeSantis appointee
resigns after alleged KKK photo surfaces
the picture reportedly shows Jeffrey
Moore at a Halloween party wearing a Ku
Klux Klan hood and robe a Florida
Republican has left his job after a
photo of him allegedly in a KKK costume
made the rounds online this is Gadsden
County Commissioner Jeffrey Moore he's a
republican he was hand-picked by Ron
DeSantis in July he has resigned from
the Board of Commissioners uh per the
Tallahassee Democrat the photo I love
these words reportedly shows more at a
Halloween party wearing a KKK hood and
robe and then you see the image here and
it has not been disputed that this is
more and he did resign after all
seemingly conceding that indeed it is
him in the picture Moore is the one
white person on the board with four
black Commissioners oh boy lives in a
county where 55 percent of the residents
are black according to U.S census data
you know one of the things I was
wondering is is there such a thing as a
KKK costume like what I mean by that is
when I Googled KKK costume you know how
on Amazon and from I don't know Target
and Walmart
you can get like a honeybee costume you
can get a uh you know Peter Pan costume
I didn't find anybody selling KKK
costumes what I found were listings on
eBay for actual bona fide KKK uniforms
and the idea of a costume seems to make
it more benign than it really is we just
have to come to terms with reality these
are the types of people
in this political movement these are the
types of people that are circulating in
Florida Republican politics and at what
point do we say these aren't that rare
of exceptions yes it's not predominant
it would be silly and it would be
inaccurate to say the majority of the
Republican party is KKK members or
would-be KKK members or people
fantasizing about being in the KKK dough
of course not of course not but it's
also not that rare my surprise is that
the guy ended up resigning because very
often you know the move in the Trump era
is you just double down you never admit
anything you double down you say they're
trying to cancel me it's cancel culture
and all with you know what happened to
jokes what happened to speech this is my
speech or whatever else and you don't
apologize and you just stick with it and
oftentimes it works Trump did it and it
got him elected president many times we
said in 2015 2016 this has to be the
straw that breaks the camel's back this
has to be the end of trump and then it's
not so the surprise to me is that this
ended up with a resignation
um
that's what it is if you're wondering
what this looks like and whether this is
only purportedly a KKK uniform we will
have the picture on our Instagram which
you can find at davidpackman show quick
break and we will be right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to have back on the program today
Michael Cohen former personal attorney
to Donald Trump also host of the Maya
culpa podcast and author of The
forthcoming book Revenge how Donald
Trump weaponized the U.S Department of
Justice against his critics it's out on
October 11th and you can pre-order it
already on Amazon Michael great having
you on I appreciate it good to see you
David so I mean I don't really by the
way just to let you know you can
actually pre-order a signed copy Edition
signed copy if you go to Revenge
hyphenthebook.com Revenge
hyphenthebook.com for signed copies
beautiful
um there are at least four
investigations right now into the former
president uh you've got the New York
Finance investigation the Mar-A-Lago
document Scandal you've got January 6th
and then you have the Georgia election
results
given your knowledge of Donald Trump is
he genuinely rattled by this stuff or
does he think he's just sort of in you
know invulnerable
well this unfortunately I can't give you
the answer to that one because Donald is
a narcissistic sociopath so how he
expresses himself as it relates to
anyone's specific issue
it's very hard to get into his head from
his body language I can tell you that
this mod that this Mar-A-Lago raid
really got to him
um
but so did the Tish James lawsuit that
is now confronting him because that
attacks his you know his ego it attacks
what basically he's lived for his whole
life which is to be able to impress upon
others how rich he is and this 220 page
indictment
it negates all of that by simply showing
that he's really nothing more than just
a petty con man
you explain during your testimony under
oath years ago I don't even remember now
exactly when it was it's all kind of
been a blur but you explained this
strategy
of claiming that an asset is worth more
if you want to use it as collateral for
a loan but claiming that the very same
asset is worth less if you're trying to
reduce your property taxes that that you
owe how explicit was that strategy when
you were Trump's personal attorney was
it openly discussed
so as I explained and I the I think
you're referring to the 2018 testimony
before the house oversight committee was
the late great Elijah Cummings gotta
rest his soul
um every year
Alan weisselberg and I would be called
into Donald's office
at which point in time Donald would say
after looking through the personal
financial statement of the year before
how much more money he believes that he
is worth
and how he wants the personal financial
statement to reflect that now
one of the things was
the the reason why he was doing it and
the initial reason
was for Forbes Magazine he is obsessed
with being on that Forbes 400 list
but he didn't want to just be on the
list he of course wanted to be as high
on the list as he possibly could
and so for example in 2012 like he would
say I you know I'm not worth uh as in
2011 four billion dollars I'm actually
worth six and a half and then the year
after he would say I'm worth eight No in
fact I'm worth nine and then it would go
on and on like this and these are random
numbers that Donald would just create in
his head simply because
he would say the real estate market is
good this year meaning that my assets
are worth more well again one of the
things that he testified to in the Tim
O'Brien case was that appraisals to him
don't really mean anything it's all what
he believes the value of the price to be
it's selective pricing so to speak
and so what's interesting about that is
if he is just sort of deluded about what
these properties that were are worth
it's less overtly criminal in a sense
right because he's not saying I don't
believe that this is the value he's
deluded into thinking that it is
I don't think so what happens is he may
be he may be deluded into the total net
worth but as we would sit there for
example the famous case of his Triplex
apartment I don't care how deluded you
are in your mind you know that your
house in this case the triplex apartment
is not 33 000 square feet how do you
know such a crazy thing because you live
there not only in his case does he live
there he actually built it so imagine
you're building a house in whatever city
state you know that you live in
and somebody comes over and they said oh
um did you just build a house yeah I
just built it and then you tell me it's
33 000 square feet when in fact it's 10
800 and change clearly it's a lie then
on top of that not only as the developer
not only as the owner not only as the
person whose name is on the building you
know that no property
has ever traded not just in that
building but anywhere in New York City
for that price per square foot coming up
with what a
370 million dollar valuation on his
apartment
that's not delusional right that's a
liar that's fair that's fair
um one of the things thank you for
saying that David one of the things that
uh that Donald Trump mentioned after the
pictures or were released from the
search warrant that was served at
Mar-A-Lago was you know the pictures
make it look like my office is a mess
and my office is not really a mess
um however there are older pictures of
Trump's office where there are you know
books uh and and papers stacked all over
the place and and it does sort of seem
like a mess was it typical that the
offices were a mess
No in fact his office was extremely
um
it was extremely clean and organized
um there were times that his desk would
have papers cluttered on it but
remember something I'm talking about
Trump Tower on the 26th floor what he
would do is he would have stacks of
magazines and papers in the front of the
desk whereby of course your chair if you
were in a meeting with him would be that
and those magazines would have covers of
him on it or articles of him and if you
were let's say David Pacman comes into
Donald Trump for whatever the reason
might be you could sometimes end up
leaving with a little bag full of
magazines and newspaper clippings and
you know a little piece of a silver or a
gold Trump chocolate bar things like
that I mean you walk out there you think
that this was some sort of a carnival
that people are handing things or a job
fair that's really what it would look
like but for the most part his desk was
rather organized now
when the FBI raided Mar-A-Lago what
you're looking at is the office which is
above the um catering hall
and all of these documents are on the
floor I believe that they were placed on
the floor by the FBI so that they could
so that they could um photograph it when
the FBI raided my hotel room it was
funny my wife had several thousand
dollars
um that she had collected
for you know um from the real real on
items that she had sold and she would do
it so she wouldn't have to tell me to
buy it and it was in the safe with her
money and in fact on the envelope it
said real real money so she would know
what she was getting they fanned it out
it with something like
six thousand dollars or something like
that they fanned it out like they just
raided and found Escobar's billions and
you know they this is this is what they
do but I do have to say that when they
came in they were professional they were
respectful they did not destroy the
place they they were they did their job
and they did it the right way and I
suspect that they did the same thing at
Mar-A-Lago now why'd they lay it out on
the floor again maybe it was just so
that they could take the picture but we
have to thank them for taking those
pictures and the reason I say that is we
see that there are dozens of top secret
file folders and now we know that many
of those file folders were empty right
now rest assured he wasn't taking those
folders so that he could make menus out
of them for Mar-A-Lago you know for
their lunches and dinners there must
have been documents in there and we know
some of those documents were really
top secret
Eyes Only on the person who wrote it
nuclear secrets about whether it's our
adversary and our Ally so we have to
really thank them for doing their job
professionally I'm sure it wasn't easy
to go in and raid the home of the former
president of the United States but they
they did what they needed to do without
a doubt without a doubt speaking of
representation in in that matter and the
others what do you make of the lawyers
that show up on TV as Trump's lawyer
like Alina Haba and Christina Bob for
example this is a very different Cadre
of lawyers than the folks that were
photographed showing up in court the
other day is it just that Trump says hey
I like the way that these women look
let's hire them and make them more like
a PR type people that talk for me on TV
but they're not actually representing me
before a court is is it as simple as
that well that's not true by the way so
the answer is the visuals for him are
extremely important and he believes that
it also gives him a sense of strength
masculinity he's a very complex
individual
Alina how about does go to court oh she
does in fact she's representing Donald
in a lawsuit that I currently have
against the United States government
against the Department of Justice Donald
Trump Bill Barr for the unconstitutional
remand of me back to Otisville because I
refuse to waive my first amendment
constitutional rights so maybe what she
met Michael just to clarify is she was
not representing him in court in the
particular matter she was being
interviewed about maybe that's what she
meant that's that's correct she just
makes she just makes her statements
um I find her to be
as unqualified in court as she is on
television oh and the same thing goes
with Bob who I think is somewhat
brighter than Alina in the fact that she
doesn't always open up her mouth and say
what Donald wants her to say
um that's a real problem however what
Bob did
um is she signed a document
that the government of course is in
possession of that claimed that Donald
is not in possession and that she has
must have made some sort of a thorough
check but based upon the statements of
her client she signed an affidavit that
no additional documents exist in the
possession of trump or at Mar-A-Lago and
that's clearly a lie so is she in
trouble for it she certainly could be I
mean it's um it's a perjury charge but
look at what Donald does it's who's
going to be the next fool who's gonna be
the next Michael Cohen fool to fall on
the sword for this orange crested
Mandarin Mussolini who doesn't care
about anyone and so you begin to see
these various lawyers especially the
competent ones walk away and they walk
away for two reasons because Trump's
strategy only benefits Trump even if it
hurts the lawyer and worse than that he
doesn't tell them the truth oh let me
make a third one he also so it doesn't
pay yeah other than this recent one
um
who took the money up front and good for
him yes Save America pack of reportedly
paid something like 3.8 million to a
West Palm Beach firm in the last couple
of months so it seems like now lawyers
are demanding money up front which seems
very very smart Michael if you had to
handicap all of the different
investigations going on right now which
is the most likely to actually lead to
charges
well we already know that the Tisch
James case is the one that is the most
active and the most upfront
next up this is like a ball game right
next up is um the District Attorney's
case uh here in New York whereby Allen
weisselberg has already pled guilty
right to various criminal charges but
they have intelligently held off in the
sentencing of his case
post his testimony against the Trump
organization now let me just reiterate
for your listeners that the Tish James
case is a civil case this is the case
that will ultimately
wipe him out financially and again in
the 220 plus page document one of the
things that Tish James puts in there is
that her Baseline number
was 250 million and I want to draw
people's attention to the word Baseline
that is not the that is not the cap that
is the Baseline knowing the documents
that they used and knowing the case as
well as I do I suspect the number will
be closer to 750 million to a billion
that's what I think she will ultimately
go after now
the district attorney the case that was
originally brought by Cyrus Vance Jr now
inherited by Alvin Bragg that's a
criminal matter and that criminal matter
is
as weitzelberg would like you to believe
is against the Trump organization
how do you separate Donald Trump out
from the Trump organization his
eponymous company you cannot
let me just say one last thing that Tish
James has already referred certain parts
of that
220 page document
on tax evasion to the IRS and to the doj
so everything is beginning
to come full circle I mean I know that
we always say that the wheels of Justice
unless you're Michael Cohen that's a
48-hour ordeal yeah that was quick turn
slowly
But ultimately it does come full circle
in the book you write about I mean as
the as the the full title of the book
suggests the use of the Department of
Justice essentially as a as a tool as an
intimidation tool and as a weapon
against those who criticized Donald
Trump
how much further did he want the doj to
go and the doj was unwilling to do it
because he made way more requests than
they actually uh agreed to didn't they
yes they did now in my specific case
Jeffrey Berman just came out with a book
and again I have no regard for him or
his book so I want to be clear about
that
I think Jeffrey Berman
his actions are either one of two things
unethical or illegal
Donald Trump threw Bill Barr
placed pressure on the southern district
of New York the Department of Justice
to expunge his name from anything
related to the actions the claims that
were brought against me initially that I
ultimately pled guilty to and my book
Revenge right how Donald Trump
weaponized the United States Department
of Justice against his critics it really
takes a deep dive into everything and
Jeffrey Berman is of course named in my
book as well but what it does
What Jeffrey Berman's book does is it
validates everything that I say in my
book it shows that Donald Trump's goal
was to use the Department of Justice as
his own private Law Firm his own private
hit squad to go against people that he
didn't like myself people like James
Comey uh and you know uh and others
the uh book is an extraordinary expose
of more as you say the inner workings of
how all this was done the book is out on
October 11th but it is available for
pre-order now as well as signed
pre-order we've been speaking with
Michael Cohen the book's author and
again the book is Revenge how Donald
Trump weaponized the U.S Department of
Justice against his critics Michael
always great having you on and best of
luck with the book release thanks David
and I will speak to you soon
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right this you have to see and uh I
have to admit this this gives me great
pleasure Doug mastriano is this big lie
a proponent who is at the Capitol on
January 6th and he is the Republican
nominee for being the governor of the
state of Pennsylvania it would be a
disaster if Doug mastriano were to
become the governor of Pennsylvania but
the good news is his campaign isn't
doing very well apparently desperate to
try to fix it the Philadelphia Inquirer
reports that Doug mastriano is now
planning 40 days of fasting and prayer
to try to save his campaign
I love this for two reasons number one
he's losing and he's desperate and
that's great and it's good news for the
people of Pennsylvania but also fasting
and prayer aren't going to change the
polls for him it's not actually going to
do anything so I say do 80 Days of
fasting and prayer of course there's not
80 days left before the uh before the
election the article writes the
Republican gubernatorial candidate is
losing some support among Republican
allies as his cash-strapped campaign
turns to Twitter memes and apparently
divine intervention
you these people are a joke it was
billed as a blockbuster but it ended up
a flop if Doug mastriano's big rally
last weekend were a movie it's Rotten
Tomatoes score would be in the single
digits only a few dozen supporters
joined the Republican state senator on
the steps of the Capitol building in
Harrisburg some of them members of a
militia group
the photos looked bad because it was bad
and the Press coverage was brutal
so what is he doing now by the way
here's a picture of the rally I'm sure
it's like there's almost no one it looks
like it's just intern orientation day
uh at the Capitol
now with the election 41 days away
the head of a conservative group airing
anti-shapiro ads remember Shapiro is the
Democrat who we should all just vote for
if you live in Pennsylvania because he's
a completely uncontroversial reasonable
candidate is questioning masciano's
tactics particularly his insistence on
campaigning within an echo chamber etc
etc
so what is it that is going on now
on Monday night
mastriano's campaign posted on Facebook
a photo of two hands under the words 40
days of fasting and prayer with the
dates September 29 through November 8th
election day interceding for our
elections our state and our nation it
stated along with a verse from the book
of Isaiah mastriano wrote in the post
starting in a few days it'll be my honor
to fast with you
now as the article points out it's
unclear who mastriano expects to start
fasting on Thursday
but this is all part of this Christian
nationalist Ideology Now of course this
isn't going to do anything for him and
so my messages do it do it the message
to the voters is don't assume that we
have this in the bag no risks can be
taken here's the way that the polling is
looking right now mastriano versus Josh
Shapiro on average on average Shapiro is
leading by 9.3 almost a double-digit
lead this is a major major deal because
the risk if mastriano became the
governor is that Democrats lose the
White House in 2024. I know that some of
you might find that hyperbolic it is not
hyperbolic Pennsylvania is a state
on Which presidential elections can
hinge
presidential election is not going to
hinge on Rhode Island
it's not going to hinge on South Dakota
we know how those are going to go
many scenarios have presidential
elections depending on Pennsylvania
if Doug mastriano wins in November
and then in 2024 a Democrat narrowly
wins the presidential election in
Pennsylvania be it Joe Biden or whoever
is the nominee mastriano will try to
steal Pennsylvania for republicans and
so the consequences are absolutely
massive so it is so great that Shapiro
is up nearly double digits but
do not assume we have this in the bag
the risk is too great this one is just
so so important that no risks can be
taken now as far as Josh Shapiro and
we're going to have coverage of the
mastriano versus Shapiro debate let me
remind myself when that is
uh uh let's see I'm checking out my
calendar
it is I don't know what it is
is it tomorrow no work I'll let you know
when that debate is okay we're gonna
have the debate Josh Shapiro is not a
Democrat that pennsylvanians have to
kind of turn their nose up and say well
I'm reluctantly voting for Josh Shapiro
he's not the most Progressive Democratic
candidate but he's super smart
he's reasonable he's Common Sense he's
completely uncontroversial he's actually
a fine choice for governor of
Pennsylvania so it's all laughable the
prayer is not going to get mastriano to
catch up the 10-point deficit the
fasting certainly is not let them do it
encourage them to do it but let's not
assume that this is in the bag because
it is so important a race and we don't
want to give them any opportunity
I am going to play for you today one of
the most pathetic Donald Trump videos
that I have ever seen of Donald Trump
begging for money mentioning one of
these completely imaginary fundraising
deadlines that are of no meaning or
value whatsoever this guy is desperate
this guy is desperate and it's pathetic
listen to Trump's voice here we have a
major fundraising deadline coming up no
you don't no you this is the biggest
skin we have a deadline it's a
self-imposed deadline we've got to get 5
000 new donors by midnight tonight no
you don't you're just desperate dude and
there's never been a time like this our
country has never been so disrespected
our country has never been so low
certainly in the minds of others and
especially the leaders of other
countries all over the world yeah we
have to change it we have to bring our
country back we made it remember opinion
of the United States around the world
has dramatically improved since Donald
Trump left office every single poll
proves that America great and now we're
going to have to make America great
again yeah so I say whatever you can do
help out we have to meet the deadline
the midterms are coming up it's going to
be one of the most important elections
in the history of our country that's
true only because of the effect it may
have on 2024
so I hope you can help up and help out
we really appreciate it and good luck
yeah can I translate this uh video clip
for you this message here's the
translation
I might actually have to pay my lawyers
this time
okay that's the real message that Donald
Trump is espousing here and look at how
disastrously humiliating fundraising has
been this is an article on Yahoo News
from the Independent Trump's Super PAC
raised just forty dollars in August okay
that's not a typo that's not 40 million
it's not 4 million it's not 400 000.
okay Trump's Super PAC raised 40 dollars
in August former president Donald Trump
Super PAC raised only forty dollars in
the month of August in a sign that his
name doesn't have the fundraising pull
that it once did along with the low
August numbers the make America great
again again Super PAC only raised 351
thousand dollars in July
nothing in June by comparison in the
final fundraising quarter of last year
the very same Super PAC raised between
four and five million dollars even in
April and May it raised 864 million
dollars among some of the merchandise
that is being made available
are Jared kushner's memoir
Trump wine glasses
and a rally speech signed by Trump as
well as the opportunity to get your name
engraved on a donor wall
now as I mentioned this is really about
legal fees and the article says the
numbers come as save America pack foots
the bill for Trump's legal fees last
month it spent
3.8 million dollars on legal fees the
most spent on such fees the entire 22
2022 cycle with three million dollars
going to critten luddier and Coleman
which is a law firm based in West Palm
Beach Florida remember Maga means making
attorneys get attorneys and Maga also is
extremely lucrative for lawyers that's
for damn sure as you know Trump is going
to have legal fees because of the
Leticia James criminal referral and
lawsuit and we've got what's happening
in Georgia and we've got the Florida
situation with the Mar-A-Lago raid this
guy is going to have legal fees up to
Wazoo so when Trump shows up and he's uh
in in uh his informal wear right no no
no necktie and says we've got to meet
this fundraising deadline what he means
is I might have to pay my lawyers I
might have to pay my lawyers it is
pathetic and it is humiliating he raised
40 dollars guys forty dollars let's hope
that he raises even less we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P here's something kind of funny
so we launched the David packman show
Finance Channel and I I've mentioned
this before you can find it at
youtube.com
Pacman Finance it's no politics it's
just basic personal finance uh education
and advice and it's not specific advice
it's just general concepts that are
important to understand we're already
almost at 10 000 subscribers it is seems
to be striking a nerve last week I
showed a message from a viewer who said
what are my credentials to even talk
about this and I said well I have an MBA
specializing in financial planning those
are my credentials and it's not like a
humble brag it's just someone said what
are your credentials those are my
credentials and here is a caller who
says no no no no that's not enough
hey David
um you know I recently watched your
video on your main YouTube channel
talking about you know
um how exactly you're qualified to talk
financial matters and you said because
you had an MBA or qualified to talk on
financial matters right well David let
me guess something straight dude and NPA
does not make you qualified to talk on
financial matters okay come back when
you have a PhD or something like really
special okay David I mean get a freaking
grip dude just because you have an MBA
doesn't mean you're qualified to speak
on financial lives in fact I think the
most prudent Financial advice comes from
Dave Ramsey David you know what Dave
Ramsey has
not an MBA [ __ ]
yeah well Dave Ramsey does have a
bachelor's degree so that is something
yeah listen to be totally honest
there's people who know a ton about
personal finance and don't have any
degree in it it's actually it was sort
of like a joke
um it reminds me of some discussion we
were looking at where someone said to an
economist what qualifies you to give uh
economic uh analysis anyway and the
guy's like well I have a PhD in
economics
um it's you know we've talked about the
appeal to Authority
and the appeal to expertise's potential
cognitive biases or logical fallacies
rather not cognitive biases and the
truth is I I don't even really subscribe
to what I said which is like I know
about this stuff because of my degree
because quite frankly most of the stuff
you learn by doing and you learn by by
individual research and learning but
anyway I encourage you check out the
finance Channel subscribe for free
totally different thing the way I
describe it is
it's like Dave Ramsey without the right
wing nuttery without the Christian
messaging and without the anti-backs
that's the idea of the Pacman Finance
Channel youtube.com pacmanfinance we've
got a great bonus show for you today Joe
Biden is warning oil industry uh
companies as hurricane Ian has made
landfall in Florida and Joe Biden is
saying do not gouge the American people
on gas we will see if they will heed his
warning Joe Biden has also approved an
additional billion plus dollars in
security assistance to Ukraine are
Republicans in favor of or against this
because remember it was Biden didn't do
enough for Ukraine and also there's too
much money going there
wait so how could it be both and Donald
Trump is seeking to end his rape
accusers defamation lawsuit is this
finally going to be the end of the road
for that lawsuit or not all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com use the coupon
code indict to get yourself a discount
and we will see you then when I am
joined by producer Pat by the way
a lot of people writing in and saying
David what is up with that bruise on
producer Pat's nose he explains it on
the bonus show this week he explains
what happened to his note so please tune
in join pacman.com we'll see you on the
bonus show